My lower Iq clients,
they used to go to the government agencies that were designed to help people
find employment.
And you know,
the typical response was,
well,
just go home and type up your CV and distributes.
It's like,
yeah,
uh,
you're,
you just go like,
I can't use a computer.
I can't type,
I don't know what a CV is.
It's like it's,
it's a nonstarter and all three councils,
right?
That's right.
So in the United States are 51 million people with iqs under 85 and there were
about 43 million people living in poverty.
Do you think those Venn diagrams intersect?
Yeah.
You're,
well,
we should also be clear about this because it is so politically suspect is that
it's not like it's,
it's,
it's self evident that people who have less cognitive capability are likely to
end up poor because there are serious,
complex problems in life that the Septum that they have a difficult time dealing
with and they can't learn as quickly.
And so the relationship between poverty and intelligence is self evident.
If you're willing to think it through for any length of time.
It doesn't mean that everybody who's rich that is,
it doesn't mean that everyone who is rich is smart and it doesn't mean that
everyone who is horror is stupid.